[Música]
la recién llegada embajadora
estadounidense a ucrania visitó uno de
los lugares más golpeados por los
bombardeos por dianca de get bring
afirmó que la casa blanca respaldará las
investigaciones por crímenes de guerra
se cumplen 33 años de la masacre en la
plaza tiananmen de beijing entre el 3 y
el 4 de junio de 1989 el ejército chino
arremetió contra una protesta de
estudiantes y trabajadores que
rechazaban el autoritarismo por tercera
vez consecutiva el gobierno prohibió las
conmemoraciones ampliaremos desde
beijing
'ecuador regula la migración de
venezolanos una nueva norma permite que
quienes hayan entrado al país de manera
regular antes del 3 de junio de 2022
adaptar por la visa de residencia
temporal le dio una amnistía quienes
tienen el permiso de permanencia
vencidos analizamos en esta emisión
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y gracias
por estar con nosotros
comenzamos con la actualidad en ucrania
este sábado la embajadora de eeuu en ese
país bridget behling recorrió foro de
ancap uno de los pueblos de la región de
kiev más golpeados por la guerra
la diplomática caminó entre los
escombros de los edificios bombardeados
y por las calles donde hace meses
encontraron decenas de cadáveres tras la
retirada rusa una escena similar a la
que se vio en el suburbio cercano de
butch a brink viajó con la fiscal
general ucraniana irina benedicto va la
embajadora aplaudió sus labores y afirmó
que la casa blanca proporciona ayuda
técnica para la investigación de
crímenes de guerra brin llegó aquí es
base apenas cinco días tras la
reapertura de la embajada estadounidense
y esto fue lo que dijo desde boro dianca
y también estamos utilizando muchos
otros mecanismos para apoyar este
proceso y puedo decirles que
personalmente me aseguraré de que aquí
en el terreno hagamos todo lo posible
para apoyarlo a través de varios
mecanismos del gobierno de eeuu ya sea a
través del departamento de estado usaid
u otras agencias mientras las fuerzas de
moscú libran una batalla sin cuartel
para tomar el donbass quien intenta
reforzar sus posiciones en otras partes
del país como ocurre en el norte de
gerzón la ciudad que los rusos se
tomando al comienzo de la guerra pero
aunque el ejército ucraniano ha
recuperado algo de terreno no puede
hacer un contraataque significativo por
ahora pues carece de armamento moderno
reporteros de france24 en inglés se
desplazaron al frente de esta región
hasta hace unas semanas la posición de
este regimiento ucraniano estaba en
primera línea los rusos están ahora a 6
km de distancia al concentrar sus
esfuerzos en la región del donbass a
veces han permitido a kiev recuperar
terreno en otros lugares como aquí en el
norte de gerson y poco a poco
note que la mayor parte del tiempo solo
defendemos nuestras posiciones pero en
algunos lugares contra atacamos esta
mañana nuestra fuerza aérea bombardeó
posiciones enemigas
el ejército ucraniano ha retomado
algunas posiciones clave en la zona pero
un contraataque mayor aún no está en la
agenda por ahora la meta es impedir una
nueva entrega de armas rusas pero esta
unidad del ejército regular tiene poco
armamento construido para ese objetivo
como lo muestra esta pieza de artillería
de la época soviética
necesitamos cañones ms 777 que pueden
disparar hasta 30 kilómetros de
distancia y esta arma antitanque solo lo
podemos usar una vez
pero él javelin puede recargarse
continuamente con nuevos misiles de
las entregas de armas occidentales aún
no han tenido efecto importante en el
frente el ejército ucraniano carece de
artillería moderna y lanzadores de
misiles ante ataque de última generación
como stay avelina americano este joven
soldado dice que ha podido hacer buen
uso de la eficacia del arma
gates foundation 8 instructor quien fue
entrenado en la región de kiev por un
instructor americano en información duró
dos semanas en la región de lugares
destruimos unos 20 objetivos con esto
nos faltan armas como esta para cubrir
todas nuestras posiciones en el frente a
ocasiones
los oficiales ucranianos han dicho en
repetidas ocasiones que el suministro de
armas modernas podría cambiar el curso
de la guerra
cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a asia hoy
se conmemora en 33 años de la masacre en
la plaza tiananmen de beijing cuando el
ejército chino reprimió las protestas
ciudadanos por la democracia en el
aniversario la asociación de madres de
tiananmen volvió a pedir que se
esclarezcan los hechos para saber con
precisión qué ocurrió en la noche del 3
al 4 de junio de 1989 cuando soldados
del ejército de liberación popular chino
se abrieron paso hasta la plaza y
arremetieron contra miles de estudiantes
y trabajadores llevaban varias semanas
manifestándose aún hoy no hay una cifra
oficial de cuántas personas murieron
podrían ser entre 200 y 2000 por su
parte del gobierno chino censura el tema
y por tercera vez consecutiva el parque
de la victoria en hong kong fue
acordonado y se prohibieron las
reuniones desde beijing nuestro
corresponsal adrián foncillas nos amplía
las fuertes medidas de seguridad
se cumple otro aniversario de tiananmen
con sordina porque el asunto sigue
siendo un tabú aquí 33 años después no
habido ninguna referencia en la prensa
nacional todas las alusiones en internet
han quedado censuradas y han aumentado
las medidas de seguridad los accesos a
la plaza donde hoy era evidente que
había más policía y se habían instalado
además cámaras de reconocimiento facial
nada de eso es nuevo en la china
continental si es más reciente en hong
kong donde hasta no hace tanto tiempo se
podía recordar aún la matanza de
tiananmen especialmente con las vigilias
de velas encendidas en el parque
victoria en memoria de los caídos esa
práctica quedó prohibida a raíz de la
aprobación de la ley de seguridad
nacional en 2019 siempre con la excusa
de los peligros del coronavirus el grupo
que organizaba esas vigilias en la
alianza de hong kong ha sido perseguido
por ser un agente extranjero en tareas
de incitación de la subversión la
policía ha desaconsejado a la ciudadanía
que participe en asambleas ilegales y ha
amenazado con detenciones así que
también con se desvanece la huella de
tiananmen como demuestra la retirada en
monumentos conmemorativos de los campos
universitarios
en yemen se aplica la extensión de la
tregua entre los útiles cercanos a irán
y las fuerzas del gobierno apoyados por
la coalición liderada por arabia saudita
la semana pasada a las partes acordaron
prorrogar por dos meses más el cese al
fuego que firmaron el 2 de abril sin
embargo los rebeldes todavía siguen
asediando la ciudad de taiz la tercera
más grande de la nación aquí les
contamos cómo es vivir aislados en medio
de la guerra
mohsén al mar y un paciente yemení con
cáncer tiene que conducir más de tres
horas por estrechas carreteras entre las
montañas para recibir quimioterapia en
taiz una ciudad que ha quedado en gran
medida aislada del resto de yemen
durante los más de siete años de guerra
antes de que los rebeldes sus pies
cortarán las carreteras y sitiaran la
ciudad tardaba menos de una hora en
llegar al país
a veces pierdo las citas por un pinchazo
u otros problemas en las carreteras
llenas de baches esto significa que no
podré recibir mi dosis de quimioterapia
los pies que controlan la mayor parte
detalles siguen bloqueando las rutas de
suministro e interrumpiendo el flujo de
ayuda humanitaria a la población
asediada comprar comida ir a la escuela
y acceder a los servicios médicos es una
lucha diaria para sus residentes el cese
al fuego se ha alargado pero para la
ciudad de taiz nada ha cambiado de la
cta
los últimos ocho años asedio y guerra
han hecho que en taiz falte lo esencial
de la vida humana normal ya sea en lo
que respecta a la educación que ha
colapsado por completo oa los servicios
sanitarios no hay ninguno muchas
personas mueren en los cruces de
carreteras en la tercera ciudad más
grande de yemen resaltan las cicatrices
de la guerra miles de casas y monumentos
nacionales han sido destruidos por los
fuertes bombardeos en el conflicto entre
la coalición liderada por arabia saudita
y los útiles desde 2015 las
organizaciones internacionales mantienen
la esperanza de que esta tregua puede
abrir el camino a una paz a largo plazo
en yemen pero los residentes detalles
son escépticos
esperábamos que la tregua levantara el
asedio y abriera las principales
carreteras pero el fracaso de estas
negociaciones nos ha decepcionado
la guerra se ha cobrado la vida de más
de 350.000 personas y ha empujado 17
millones de yemeníes a la hambruna y los
residentes detalles no en un final
cercano
el gobierno ecuatoriano guillermo lasso
lanzó un nuevo proceso para regular la
migración de venezolanos el decreto 436
permite que quienes hayan entrado al
país de manera regular antes del 3 de
junio de este año puedan optar por la
visa de residencia temporal y además le
dio una amnistía a los migrantes y a sus
familias que tengan el permiso de
permanencia vencido para analizar el
tema nos acompaña desde nueva york
william murillo ecuatoriano y presidente
de 01 800 migrantes una organización que
asesora la llegada de latinoamericanos
bienvenidos señor murillo a france24 y
empecemos por explicar qué implica para
los venezolanos en ecuador esta
regularización
la estatua declara nosotros estamos
contentos porque esto significa la
regularización de ciudadanos que estaban
en las sombras y que lamentablemente
esto provocaba varias violaciones a sus
derechos como ciudadanos especialmente
en el área laboral que eran
prácticamente
muy explotado nosotros consideramos la
respuesta por parte del presidente lazo
es muy bienvenida esperamos que el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores y
las demás organizaciones del estado que
van a tener que cumplir o hacer cumplir
esta este decreto lo hagan de forma
efectiva porque evidentemente el aporte
de los ciudadanos venezolanos hacia la
economía formal porque muchos de ellos
están en las sombras de una economía
oscura seguramente van a apoyar a la
economía ecuatoriana y eso asombra
noticias sin embargo hay un vacío en
este decreto porque la norma aplica para
los migrantes regulares y por lo menos
el 62% de los venezolanos que entraron a
ecuador lo hicieron de manera irregular
según las cifras de la agencia de la onu
a los refugiados es decir que esto
dejaría a la mayor parte de los
migrantes por fuera ante este panorama
que tan efectivo es el decreto
bueno yo creo que todo proceso de
regularización para extranjeros en
cualquier país es importante y si es que
se están quedando fuera como parece que
es de estas circunstancias yo creo que
los acuerdos ministeriales podrán de
alguna forma ayudar para que esto sea
efectivo recordemos que es un decreto
ejecutivo y esto también se puede
cambiar sólo puede mejorar si es que es
necesario y evidentemente las cifras
serán las que determinen a ciencia
cierta cuál es o cuántos son los
migrantes venezolanos y de otras
nacionalidades que también podrían tener
acceso a esta amnistía que ha presentado
el gobierno ecuatoriano y ahora hagamos
una mirada latinoamericana porque
colombia había regulado la migración de
venezolanos con un decreto muy similar
al que hoy adopta ecuador en este
sentido que está cambiando en la región
respecto al tema
yo creo que la perspectiva de que los
venezolanos no van a regresar a su país
por ahora y eso significa de que muchos
están buscando una situación permanente
una regularización tener accesos a
fuentes de trabajo a derechos que muchas
de las veces por ser indocumentados o
por ser extranjero los están
discriminando y que esta vez ya con un
camino a la legalización con un camino
por parte del estado para poder
permanecer de forma legal dentro del
ecuador esto va a permitir de que muchos
venezolanos tengan una oportunidad para
asentarse y poner raíces mucho más
profundas pensando ya a largo plazo
imagino también de que sus hijos sus
familias van a poder ser beneficiadas y
esto en términos generales yo creo que
es muy positivo para la región porque
esto indica también un camino a seguir
para otros países es muy positivo para
el país porque van a fomentarse nuevos
lazos económicos
muy positivo para las familias porque ya
no van a tener esa preocupación de que
quizás mañana me van a deportar william
murillo gracias por este análisis de la
migración aquí en france 24
y cambiamos de deporte porque cambiamos
de noticia porque hay una nueva campeona
en el roland garros este sábado la
tenista polaca y número uno del mundo se
alzó con la victoria tras vencer en dos
sets a la estadounidense coco gov quien
con 18 años jugaba su primera final de
un grand slam este es el segundo título
para el viaje que en el torneo francés
los detalles con nuestra periodista en
parís natalia ruiz y dad
invencible inatajable e imparable esa es
y desvían tecla número uno del mundo
quien hoy consiguió su segundo título en
roland garros lo hizo ante códigos de
eeuu en tan sólo dos sets 6-1 6-3 y una
hora 08 minutos de juego un partido en
que ambas jugadoras tuvieron que tomarse
su tiempo antes de poder meterse de
verdad en este partido pero fue
estudiante que quien logró hacerlo
primero quien logró finalmente plantear
el partido tal y como ella lo había
preparado para el día de hoy mientras
que la estadounidense de 18 años pues en
realidad acumuló demasiados demasiados
errores errores no forzados empezando
además con su servicio que es uno de sus
fuertes sin embargo la norteamericana
comenzó abriendo con una doble falta en
su servicio de juego en todo caso fue
gigante que ya en la segunda manga logró
finalmente igualar el 20 por el que iba
ya arriba el cojo voz y finalmente
terminar este partido sin problemas una
nueva victoria entonces para la número
uno del mundo ya es su sexto torneo que
lleva se lleva este año y una victoria
consecutiva número 35 igualando el rey
de venus williams sin embargo para
corrido las cosas no se han terminado
porque ella tiene mañana la final en
dobles junto a su compatriota jessica
peluda y ambas van a enfrentarse a dos
francesas kristina mladenovic y karim
garcía hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]